de quoi elle parle cette histoire un
type entre chez les gens ils tuent les
parents et le parc des filles et il
reste avec elle et les cadavres des
parents jamais écrire des histoires
[Musique]
insi dancing ghost landes et de loin
votre livre le plus personnel c'est un
best-seller tout le monde adore tout le
monde t'aime je sais pas d'où vient ton
talent ma chérie qu'est ce que tu fais
ici
cette capacité à créer des univers bien
à toi
la vraie question c'est pourquoi avez
vous écrit ce livre pour ne pas devenir
dingue
continuer à revivre ce qui s'est passé
je suis tu vas me laisser mourir tout ça
elle n'aurait pas dû rester dans cet
oiseau y a personne ici
y a personne tu entendes je sais ce que
tu attends ta soeur ils m'ont brisé que
ma couru s'amuse avec tout ça y est tu
comprends ça qu'est ce que tu m'as fait
accepte ce qui s'est passé presque
atteint depuis
[Musique]